love love passion show up that is easy
for you to become a ranger
when I came here in 1993
[Music]
there was no animals my jet air was
empty before tourism before bringing
animals before everything there's a need
of from team to protect my Jetta
I remember 1995 before Oscar bucks when
I was on patrol it was a Saturday on
that day
we come across perches there are many
more than 10 with the ak-47 underway a
linear theory just bathing there was a
fire which as shooting direct to us
we tried our best but unfortunately one
of my best friend Linux my mother's was
killed by those bushes that day
so I went home my harvest my wife
I said my friend was cleared by my
chance so I wonder if the job
but after today's issue in areas I'm
much too cozy with more life so let me
continue I continue working as a ranger
yes
[Music]
when I was posted in my Jetta what she
was very very high because there was a
wall and it wasn't big people were
running from wall I think we are being
there we points that contributed a lot
or the killing of animals here in Minami
so when Afghan parks came in we saw a
lot of changes to the park the concept
of African art is protecting these lost
assets that remain on the African
continent there's so many reserves that
need some intervention or another the
idea is to bring in key staff members
that pass on years of experience and
ultimately live in particular countries
manage their own reserves it's done
through conservation law enforcement and
first collaboration with communities as
well so you really do have three legs
which ultimately leads to the
sustainability of a reserve
the African Parks was founded in 2000
and they're quite a few parks now we've
got 15 parks in nine countries animals
can't migrate across the landscape
anymore and we as humans have got a role
to play and actually physically move
those animals each reserves got a unique
bunch of genes and from there we can
then cross populate amongst the reserves
as well
Magette II was one of the three African
parks within Malawi
the jetty is a very special place it's
plus incredible Bush Haven filled with
the most enormous trees it is something
to behold virtually everything was
extinct in 2003 when African parks came
around it was poached out within years
of African parks coming in and maybe
even months things started to change
[Music]
when FK parks plans to relocate
Chinaman's Rangers we are the forefront
on those activities because he see our
job to protect those animals in 2018 it
was a good year for Majid because for
the first time we have jobs these
giraffes I'm from South Africa and Yana
Park in Malawi so we have not 15 just in
my jet no my did what reservist repent
to have cheetah for the first time
cheetah have been eradicated from 91% of
their historical range in Africa machete
offers us an opportunity to bring back
all the naturally occurring large mammal
species including cheetah so that we
could restore ecological integrity
Cheeta have an important ecological role
to play in the environment and that is
to regulate prey numbers
[Music]
relocating wild born cheaters over such
long distance is a very risky affair but
in the end we know that the benefits
outweigh the risks because we've
attempted cheater introductions into new
countries and they've worked and we can
only hope that the machete
reintroduction will go the same way
so yeah the cheetahs are surprisingly
doing very well
three of them have not traveled before
it's much remarkable to see how relaxed
they are in the cracks things are
looking good we've got another four five
hours together and then we can set them
free from these transfer price
[Applause]
it's easily be verified about the party
yes Justin even five minutes ago or we
have one just releasing their watch that
got data for I just spotted the two
fishermen here along with it we receive
a lot of pause for I'm purchase yeah so
mr. Moyer please can you organize it to
so that you quickly go into that area
yes most of watches here around my jetty
they used to go for ivory vertices of
compacts can mean most of watches they
look just for meat or fish which is also
illegal and machete yes
as arranged as we working hand-in-hand
with the communities sometimes they
committed themselves passing hey someone
is a skewed an animal or they have a gun
they can call me or give any Ranger that
what
[Music]
control well found two fishing lines we
have also found at this location Kangana
Onehunga knife over Oscar parks is
supporting the communities around
machete giving them small businesses
like keeping beings that also
contributes to the low pressure of
washing
we are going now to Nami Simpa that is
in the masa district where I will be
meeting a big Palace we have
approximately 2 R and theta beekeepers
and roughly will be meeting half of them
today the changing of the mindset of
people it's not an easy job
believe you me talking about human
behavior changing that behavior from
poaching to somebody who is able to
support we need to have that buy-in from
the communities because whenever I say
we want to community members to own the
park they need to so to be involved in
the decision-making process
so my humble responsibility is to try to
make sure that the communities out there
they see they really need to support my
jetty to create an emotion ownership
into the communities the
highly-processed excites the Ingram is
ready the drama group with the genome
are also they are aware people have said
now realizing each and every person in
the community is able to make a decision
to contribute to their well-being
currently we have hide my go honey in
the southern part of Malawi so far we
have distributed 600 beehives we are
planning to Hawaii not less than 6,000 a
beehives installed around our catchment
areas
we paid beekeepers cash and from there
we take the honey then we sell it to to
the people why in need of the honey
[Music]
[Music]
when we go into the communities we
become part of the communities and they
come part of us people are appreciating
that we are together we are moving
together we are not leaving them behind
[Music]
all right so we 40 hours into the
relocation and then we finally got the
Cheetahs intermediate to wildlife
reserve you have just called educate
these children these crates to be honest
and this is my father longer significant
to our well she is incredible our
previous service 28 hours so we really
have push these cats what we are happy
digital now coming it'll be my first
time Pro Series jitters
we're releasing together so we get the
other one
ready
[Music]
it's been a really long wait but it's
excited to see you know it's been a good
couple of years in the planning and to
eventually see each thing Ligeti is a
awesome sight an animal suit if travels
really well
nicely relaxed actually falling exactly
it's a bit of bonding going on in Oakley
in a month's time we'd be able to
release them into New Jersey and they
can run wild
in a landscape where they haven't been
for many many years
[Music]
it's it's something very special in a
bgt story and it's been a long long
mission but he eventually accomplished
what we set out to do from the start
[Music]
when I go out in the park and I see a
lot of one was I feel very happy that
I've done something good
[Music]
if you work hard you achieve something
Oh Joe Joe Joe Joe Hey Joe I do all the
different activities that take place
with an Imagi to be at law enforcement
beard community work via conservation
they all some form of symbiotic
relationship they all flow into each
other if one is not there we're not able
to function properly we work as a team
we don't work in isolation we wake as a
team that's the most important thing
that has contributed this access door of
magic
Magette is a model Park now because we
have lions leopard elephants rhinos eg
does so it has got everything
in place
they hold they know me there's water in
my Jetley
and when I hear from bringers that gee
I'm a good person I feel very happy
that's why working here for so long I
feel like this is my home I work here in
budget
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you